we need the positivity of dancing with
the stars that's why i always love doing
these interviews because
there's no there's no drama there's no
tragedy it's just a fun dancing show we
need this right now
everybody needs that it's just such an
uplifting show we're
it's so incredibly proud to be part of
it and we've got some amazing new pros
this season um
shout out to daniella and massive shout
out to brit stewart
she wasn't here uh last season and she's
like a really really really close friend
of us so i'm so stoked for her
she's amazing okay i just talked to
britt literally just got off with her
and um we were talking about how the
married partners such as yourselves will
have to be living apart
and i asked her well who do you think
will have the easiest time in the
toughest time
who do you think she said really who do
you think she said
i reckon she said the easiest will be
she knows she probably knows us about
the best did she say we have the easiest
she said you'd have the easiest time you
know um
it's so funny when our amazing producers
told us okay so we have some news for
you you're gonna have to be quarantining
separately
i laughed and it was so embarrassing
because they were like are you happy i
was like i just i'm nervous
i just started laughing i just don't
know why but also
we came to the executive decision that i
would be the one moving out because
she would burn the house down yeah she
was here so i i think we made
made that choice on literally on that
just to say maybe i think it's best that
you go
and stay there and i'll stay here lots
of face time
and you know it's really important to do
these things it's great that the
producers have thought of this because
you know
yeah they're trying to come up with all
the safe angles lots of masks lots of
distancing there's
lots of things happening um and this is
this is one way of making sure that
everyone's safe
strong and the show goes on because we
need the show
we really do we love the fact that
everybody's worked so hard
up until even just this point to
allow the show to happen you basically
said look
yes we're married but we're okay with
living apart to get this show on the air
i was like i'm totally fine i'm just
kidding
totally fine okay key questions one how
would she burn the house down
well you know i forget the gas
great chef
sasha's also getting the dog sasha's
also getting the job
i'm getting the boost the house would be
a
mess i'm taking my i'm taking my artwork
because i need a lot of our i'm okay so
you're
you're only taking things that aren't
living no living things are safe
all of my plants i am may or may not be
fake
i am a how would i say it man
man housewife
a man made man housewife so not one of
those things is true because you're not
a man-made man and you're not a
housewife
yeah well we'll we'll call you you know
what i mean
you're the more responsible one it
sounds like really
i'll give him that emma will you take
your mirror ball with you for good luck
yes no
said that you guys would have the
easiest time because you're both
just very strong individuals on your own
but what will it be like
i know you guys are also best friends
how much will you miss each other
oh it's gonna it is a in all seriousness
it is gonna be really weird and really
hard because normally
you're in a lot of downtown star season
even uh either i'm traveling or
he's traveling and so but we still get
to see each other on sunday or monday
and this time we will but it might be
like from across the ballroom
let's be realistic baby she always tells
me during every season that i stress her
out
he does stress me out a little bit like
sometimes i would come home
every night and he would be like further
along in the routine than me
and he's and he's stressing and he's
like oh my god do you think it's good
enough and i'm like
you're like on next week's dance and i'm
still completing this week's stand
so then i get like oh my god i should be
further along than i am
but no it is going to be hard because we
are like we are best friends
but i know we're going to have each
other on speed dial all the time
we even we live together right now we're
in each other's faces for 24 hours we
still manage to call and text each other
a lot it's really weird even if we're
just doing separate sides of the house
so how long i know it'll take a lot how
long will you be apart for
well as long as it you know i'm going
to uncomfortably i'm moving in thursday
this week
and for as long as we're in the
competition we will be apart
that's what that's the information that
we know at the moment what was your
reaction when you
got this news that you would have to be
totally apart from celebrating i laughed
i laughed because i was nervous you know
i'm
it's so embarrassing sometimes i laugh
when things get really like
awkward or nervous so they told me and i
was like oh my god
you won't even be able to hug and kiss
each other no literally it's not even
six feet i think they're enforcing eight
feet distance
we can't prep together we can't i can't
if i've forgotten something at home bear
in mind i'm a woman right you know
like i like my stuff um as as
non-materialistic as i like to think i
am you know i have my vices
so when i leave in a couple of days
that's
that's it like if i forget something
we're gonna have to negotiate a way to
like for him to leave you outside
sanitize it and then to me come for me
to come and pick it up
i can't i mean i guess it's important to
you know follow these rules if you want
to keep the show oh
yeah because the idea right would be you
don't want multiple pros to get it
and for everybody to go down for the
count but
i i'm secretly wondering after lindsay
and whitney both announced pregnancies i
was wondering
is this actually them trying to prevent
any more dancing with the star's
pregnancies so that the cast stays
around
yes i know can you imagine them having a
meeting in the border of guys this
this too we need to actually like stop
the pregnancies because we need a show
so
no they would never do that and it's i
think it's going to be
um i think it's going to be interesting
for people who
might want to try to do that but not
saying that that's us
well val has first well i know this is
sasha because sasha and val have been
telling me for a long time they have
baby fever and they're ready so the boys
have baby fever
right hey if i don't think i could carry
it
and have it that'd be perfect i would do
it in a heartbeat
i'll look after it okay well you guys
have until thursday
yeah thursday exactly right you see he's
either like you know it's a baby or it's
a german shepherd i'm like hey what
rescue place is supposed to be
all right well i as i said i was just
talking to brit britt said she thinks
this is going to feel
like a brand new show tell me how it
will why are you guys all saying that
well i feel like the sheer fact that so
much of the show is just
a human connection and interaction now
when we
uh rehearse throughout the week we can't
go into each other's rooms we
usually do this thing called show and
tell where later on in the week we'll go
into each of those rooms and we'll sit
down and we'll watch each other perform
and it's really handy we'll give each
other notes i'll go into someone's room
like theo will
help me so much i'll i'll call him i'll
say can you come in here for a sec
he'll come and we'll work out some stuff
together and we do that for everybody
like all the pros are like that all the
celebrities we all
they all like to meet in the little
crafty area and have tea and talk about
how their feet are killing them
and oh my god the cha cha is the worst
no the rumble's the worst
and now we can't have that but it's
going to be
different because the cameras are going
to be in the room with us
the entire time so it's going to be very
interesting like you and your partner
are going to have
everything recorded and um i think the
things that are going to come up from
that is going to be
hilarious having a meeting with the
executive producers and the producers
and
them telling us an insight of what's
gonna happen
i think it's gonna it's like even
listening to that these changes i think
are gonna stay on after all you know
this whole pandemic has gone because
these changes are pretty cool
unfortunately we can't say too much yeah
but um
they really they they found the best
formula and the best way
for this show to happen and i think
this is gonna definitely up the show and
definitely
up the dancing and definitely up the
effects
and definitely like make people want to
watch it to see like
oh wow that's how that happened yeah
we're going to make history this season
why do you think it's going to up the
dancing well there's there's just so
many
little things that were in the mix that
we can't just say yet
um that a full-on game changes that when
when we heard them we were like
oh gosh why didn't we do this before
this is gonna be epic
i think it's gonna be different in how
we dance with our partners too you know
are we gonna do close contact a lot of
the time i know that you have been
dancing with your partner and i guess
you know in a sense quarantining with
them but there was a discussion like
is it going to change the the way we
think about dancing and it's going to be
it's going to be really creative and
keep us on our toes and there's going to
be a lot
some fresh new looks plus don't forget
we have
more pros this season so everybody's
going to be trying really hard to just
pull out the stops and i think it's
going to be really unique
and i'm sure or i'm hearing that the
cast is going to be phenomenal i don't
know who anyone is yet but it's going to
be great
the cast is going to be great
you